AY YO WASSSS FUCKING GOOD!
Titty Crusher 1985 here
Back at it again with another live update,
Thank you for tuning in today;
Let's get started.
First of all, don't take this video the wrong way.
I know this is the kind of video where I'm trying to explain my perspective of some things...
...and...
everyone just understands what I'm saying the wrong way and it just backfires and it's like why do I even bother trying to make an update video
by being transparent with you guys.
Anyway.
Are we good to go?
Okay.
Cool.
I was uh, sick about a week ago
Which I am sure you know
from all the constant mobbing, and uh... self pity that you've seen on Twitter and here on Youtube.
*giggle*
I'm a very routine driven person, I have like a strict way I do videos every day.
I wake up, I exercise, I go to the office, I do emails, prep the video, reshoot the video, and then meetings and then I'm home. Uhh..
Now I don't have an office anymore, and now I'm taken out of my routine, I'm just like
Well fuck it, I don't wanna do any of that shit anymore.. *giggles*
I guess what I'm trying to say is that I'm tired of trying so hard... I think I'm in try hard mode with YouTube for...since I started.
I'm a very addicted personality, and I think for the past 6 or 7 years I've been addicted to YouTube 100%
But now that I was taken out of it for 7 days, which has never happened before because even if I'm sick, I would still record videos.
Which I guess is my point, it's like I don't really wanna do that anymore.
If I'm sick, I'm just gonna be sick. *giggles* I'm not gonna force myself to upload.
And this is not a moping video as like, 'oh, YouTube is so hard' or 'I want sympathy' or some shit like that.
It's more like, 'I wanna be honest. I'm tired of trying so fucking hard'
I had problems with my internet a few days ago, and I didn't know what to do and I couldn't upload properly,
2 years ago, I would have literally taken my laptop, ran outside at like 4AM trying to steal neighbors' WiFi, i did that for 2 weeks.
It was a fucking nightmare, but I was like: "I NEED TO UPLOAD VIDEOS OTHERWISE THE WORLD WILL END"
I'm tired of doing that... *giggle*
Don't ge- But here's the point.
Don't get me wrong, I'm not tired of making videos, I'm just tired of trying so fucking hard.
I wanna have a more loose approach to it.
And uh, so if you notice a change in the channel for the past couple days, my approach to YouTube has just been
THIS IS WHAT I WANNA MAKE TODAY
Like the... the PlayerUnkown video that I did, which a lot of you liked which I think is pretty cool, but
Can that be an entertaining video?
Probably not.
But I really felt like playing the game, so I was like 'I'm just gonna record myself playing it.'
and uhh, see what happens.
Now it took me 7 hours to get that gameplay, so I guess I'm still trying fucking hard. I guess I just... disproved everything I just said-
God dammit fuck I can't- can't make a simple update video.
I guess what I'm trying to say is that I don't really care about the result as much anymore, I don't care about getting more subscribers or views
Actually I do, just kidding but
not as much.
I still really enjoy reading all the comments every single day, and that's really what gives me a kick to make videos.
And I'm just focused more now on making videos that I feel like making than ever.
I just wanted to be honest and transparent about how I'm feeling about the process,
and I don't want you to take it the wrong way like I'm tired of all of it, and all that shit because that's not- that's not true.
From what I noticed, the comments have been really great, to be honest, much better than it used to be and not because you guys sympathized me or some shit
I think you generally enjoyed the content, I don't fucking know! It's so hard to tell!
But personally I find myself to be a lot happier these past days, I'm so less stressed, I'm so less fus --
It's easy to get ticked out by YouTube and uh, I find myself to be a lot less of that lately
I really, really enjoy being back here at my old old office.
It feels much more personal to be here again.
It really just feels like me alone again.
Doing my own thing,
and I think that's pretty cool!
Last but not least,
I wanna announce a green screen competition!
We've done them before, link in the description, download that video and do whatever you want with it.
Edit it in a funny way, in a funny YouTube video, I will review the best ones, you guys can help vote for the best submissions as well
The last one was fucking hilarious.
I love seeing how creative you guys are,
and it's something I see a lot more lately well. I really feel a lot more proud of my audience these days.
Just seeing how funny you guys are on Twitter and like how creative you are with these events, I think it's really cool.
People are definitely misinterpret this video, but uh...  I hope you understand anyway, maybe where I'm coming from.
I've been doing YouTube for 7 years, and I guess, I'm just really tired of being in try hard mode.
And my love for making videos and all that shit- it's still there.
I still don't wanna quit, I don't wanna stop anything,
I promise.
Everyone is always in the comments like: hE'S-HE'S GONNA SNAP ANY MINUTE! I KNOW IT! That's not the case, I promise.
Probably was a bit close for a while, but we're past that now.
We're past that, we're moving forward. THANK YOU FOR WATCHING THIS VIDEO, and as always, sister fister.
Kazoo Kid: Wait a minute!
I forgot!
Tuber simulator is getting a new update, it's basically Simcity... the update.
It's really cool, it's my favorite update so far– I know– *laughs* dead game!
but it's really fun, if you haven't checked it out in a while I definitely recommend checking it out now
We have the egg update, the pixelings, it's really cool,
and uh, I think you guys are really gonna like this one
so, if you haven't played the game in a while, now is a great time to check it out.
That's another thing, your creations in that game are so fucking cool and creative as well, I love the community that is still playing tuber and...
Yeah just check it out, link in– in bio, buy my merch... and also... buy my merch. Thank you.